olá
hoje eu vou apresentar o meu trabalho
que é a bicicleta e tecnológica
você tá vendo que na mão dessa pessoa
tem o mundo nesse mundo o mundo está
limpo só que nosso mundo verdadeiro é
poluído e pra mundo não ficar poluído a
gente não pode cortar as árvores e se
cortar ter que replantar de novo a gente
não pode gastar água e e a bicicleta
tecnológico ajuda com isso a bicicleta
tecnológica gera energia elétrica limpa
e alguém sabe o que a energia eléctrica
limpa eu vou explicar a energia elétrica
limpa a energia que não polui o meio
ambiente
toda essa energia é acumulada em
baterias no seguinte zé docentes
aparelhos que vou falar com o primeiro é
a tv porque conforme o agente pedala a
gente dá energia para ligar a televisão
de forma divertida e saudável para quem
gosta de música eu gosto
as bicicletas essas bicicletas podem
conforme a gente pedala da energia pra
tocar música entretendo todo o público e
se ao projetor além se você está vendo
aí nós podemos utilizar a energia dessa
bicicleta ecológica pra fazer um
projetor a laser
aí ele fez um menino nadando mas você
pode fazer vários desenhos e os tablets
para quem tentar net a bicicleta vem com
suporte aqui e esse suporte
você pode colocar seus tablets e não só
pretinha jogar jogo assistir vídeos
escutar músicas mas sim você pode ler um
livro ver um filme até fazer seu
trabalho
esse é a pipoqueira porque quando a
gente pedala na bicicleta ecológica
claro a gente dá energia pra poeira pra
fazer que toca às deliciosas
pra quem trabalha nas empresas as
empresas uma hora do dia
depois almoçou antes as pessoas podem e
'pedala e além de gerar energia elétrica
limpa tão bem você pode fazer algum
exercício
o que eu gosto muito é a árvore de natal
porque vocês já imaginaram que numa
simples pedalada nesta bicicleta pode
ascender milhares de lâmpadas maioria de
natal gigante
esse é o cinema
conforme está na imagem é um cinema ao
ar livre mas só uma pessoa pedalando não
várias pessoas pedalando
a gente pode gerar a energia para fazer
um projetor projeto não desculpa pra
fazer no cinema ao ar livre
aí eu me inspirei essa foto que meu
irmão está colocando no celular
na tomada para carregar e aí eu estou
contando não pra ele porque no lugar de
nos colocarmos na tomada a gente pode
perdê-la nesta bicicleta para gerar
energia elétrica limpa e as pessoas no
ano eles ganham aí tablets e nos tablets
no lugar de colocar na tomada para
carregar
eles podem eles podem pedalar na
bicicleta ecológica para gerar energia
elétrica limpa bom conclusão
eu queria colocar essa bicicleta no
pátio da escola
lá e não só na escola mas a gente também
pode colocar nos aeroportos na praças
para gerar energia elétrica limpa e
melhorar nosso mundo
obrigada